it's time for seen and unseen will we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond aroyo all right Raymond Biden is
back in action after a little rest over
the weekend well maybe it was 50 Cent on
Instagram who got Joe back into the Game
the rapper wrote Hey Joe get the blank
up we're in trouble okay he was spent
the weekend of course at the beach but
uh over the weekend he tried to reassure
the public lawyer that he was in char
charge the White House released this
video of Biden speaking to those
hostages released by Hamas thank God
watch the president here observe the
script and remember this is the White
House edit of his best
moments hello I'm so glad you're home
I'm not home I'm glad you're out hey
Matt how are you God love you I just
want to say thank you for all your
services PR well I I look that's that's
been a long serving I'm just delighted
were able to get you out we're going to
we're going to get them all out God
willing I just want to
say I hope you're all I hope you're both
not only feeling good but in good health
as
well Laura what you couldn't see there
in the wider shot he's actually got the
script in his hand like this and he's
reading it God love you good to see you
I don't know why we cut it off there but
these poor people haven't they been
through enough why do they have to
endure this now well again I always
wonder when you're just speaking in an
instant like you someone has just been
released just say we're we're praying
for you we're hoping for the best for
the Ian why do we have to read the card
but they have to give him a card or a
Del prompter Lord knows what will happen
we'll be launching missiles in five
seconds all right um Raymond the pr the
president did correct something today
with a bomic
event good afternoon
folks I'm not introducing me
marus I forgot Mark I went right I went
straight to the podium I apologize no
problem well if it started wobbly Laura
it ended well kind of I apologize I have
to go to the situation with another
issue that I have to deal with but thank
you thank you thank
you the situation he had to deal with
was probably his campaign my question is
why is he even having a bomic event
Laura in the middle of an international
crisis uh China sending a fleet of
Warships out you got a record he just
broke at the border more people crossing
than ever before in a month on top of
house sales falling to a 13ear he should
live in The Situation Room yeah well no
actually we want him out of the situ
situation room he's liable to put push
any button that there is a button in
there no but Raymond he he is like
selling a a a lemon it's a car that
everyone knows is a lemon and you're
still trying to sell well if you if you
really just this this actually is going
to you'll make it across country just
buy this car now everyone knows it's a
lemon the economy is a lemon under
Biden finally I have to share this with
you Houston mayoral candidate your pal
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee was
caught on tape trashing abusing her
staff now fox has not verified the audio
but Jackson Lee's Campaign Will neither
confirm nor deny its authenticity for us
for goodness sake get her the
information Laura here's the
congresswoman in all her glory some
stupid other did it you and and I don't
have the information nobody sent me the
information I need to uh ensure my uh
schedule boo boo did
it did it and nobody knows in my office
both of
y'all IDI
Ser what a sweetheart she she needs to
call Angie's List I think she's got a
real problem in that office but Jackson
Le's office Laur they claim this is a
low-h handed political tactic meant to
discredit a thriving mayoral campaign
well Raymond I mean tough medicine it's
it sounds like after today at the White
House it's kind of it sounds like she
could be describing the White House
right I mean that is kind of what she's
describing but the fact that those are
some colorful adjectives to describe the
White House but you know here's the
problem Jackson has been sued twice
Laura for what they claim are abusive
staff she is renowned on Capitol Hill
for sort of tossing staff aside making
life very difficult for them so this is
coming to the four notice no one in the
Biden Administration not one Democrat is
commenting on this thing imagine if this
were say Jim Jordan or McCarthy or Trump
this would be wall toall they'd just be
playing this tape on a loop it would be
its own miniseries if only the Democrats
treated China
the way they treat their own staff would
be in really good shape I mean they
never have those types of words for like
G and what he's doing to the poor Wagers
but the poor staff are making $38,000 a
year they're the problem Sheila Jackson
Lee okay all right Raymond thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else